[Music]
health care has been at the forefront of
technological development for decades a
lot of the technology has been on the
you know after you get sick and you come
in but we're we have to be much much
more in the forefront is how we pushed
how we connect the consumer to the
service that to the provider that goes
in and how we take care that was once
then in the hospital out into the
community or into the home so today
telemedicine is huge telehealth is huge
tell a site telestroke teller teller ICU
we have you know probably close to a
hundred ICUs all over the place so we
can actually from one central location
we can go we can talk to the patient in
an ICU bed at any one of our facilities
we can assess the condition of the
patient we can talk to the physician who
is at the bedside we can provide more
assistance to that physician and those
nurses as to what to do with that
patient
it actually can reduce cost overall it
actually can reduce the number of the
percentage of people Ren I see use by
electronic medicine is another area that
which is a huge advance and that's the
result of research that has been done
over the years most of it being done by
physicians in our organization where you
can wear that implantable device can
actually moderate the immune system to
deal with issues like arthritis lupus
Crohn's and many others without the use
of traditional medications so I think as
we go forward that wearable devices
implantable devices will become you know
standard the analogy I often use you you
get into your car you turn on the car a
dashboard shows up that shows you the
vital signs of the color so I'll just
imagine and this technology is available
today in many cases and it will be more
available that you have an implantable
device in your body so when you get up
in the morning a dashboard shows up on
an honor and a Fitbit type
the piece of equipment or a watch that
shows you all your vital signs the
danger with it of course is that you'll
have an awful lot more people wanting
more treatment when that happens because
they will wake up thinking oh my God
look at this my blood pressure is higher
than I think it should be and not one of
those people that believe that all this
technology will actually reduce cost the
more that people are able to identify
what's wrong with them
the more services that will be required
to be delivered which could of course
run contrary to one enough a lot of
people talk about which is how do we
reduce overall cost of healthcare I
don't think people make this connection
and these technologies will allow you to
self diagnose or diagnose more so
therefore you'll have more people with
real and perceived problems that they
did not know anything about before you
had the technological ability to
actually identify them so that is this
vicious cycle which in fact becomes a
big big part of the discussion around
healthcare cost because nothing is
static
everybody says reduce the cost at the
same time they will identify more and
more things that people can get treated
with and get treated for which of course
grows in the opposite direction
[Music]